hey Frank Kenny how the hell are you I
hate that man takes up too much time in
the coffee line wears flip-flops on
casual Fridays sucks up to the boss like
it's his damn job
who the hell does that Frank do you have
the report why are we meeting back here
what's this domain means a communication
from here on out till we meet again
thank you oh my god napping no excuse me
did you just take my salad put it back I
knew he did not just take my salad hey
Frank did you see the email free lunch
oh I sure did who the hell does he think
I am some hole in post-war Berlin
salivating over stockings of free
chocolates what what in this company
knowing your way around Excel is sex and
let's just say I make a damn good
spreadsheet so this is her yes so nice
to finally meet you she knows not of
course don't worry I'm having three
affairs Mike Brian and and we do her to
get ahead in this company except Brian
he's just hot are you serious and how
does she benefit us again office
supplies I don't appreciate how you
treated Jackie today at the water cooler
she'll be fine she already suspects
we're not for her market research idea
do you guys want another cop
don't you understand the symbolism of
this it's very sexual white people doing
a great job Frank really glad to have
you on the team I better watch out you
might have my job soon I have them rot
Rob walking vulnerable unknown in my
crosshairs now just a matter of deciding
when to strike I can hear you no he
can't
yes I can't not how this works
Wow